[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute mache ich einen Maulwurfkuchen mit Erdbeeren.
125 Gramm Butter,
100 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
einen Teelöffel Vanilleextrakt,
drei Eier,
160 Gramm Mehl,
zwei Teelöffel
Backpulver,
40 Gramm Kakao
und 125 Gramm
Milch.
Ich mache gerade den Maulwurfkuchen,
weil die Ela im Kindergarten ist
und meine Mama ist gerade drüben und hat einen Termin.
Jetzt verrühren wir die Butter
mit dem Zucker und der Prise Salz
cremig.
Oh!
Alles weg.
Die Spickzettel!
Oh!
Dauert jetzt wieder eine Ewigkeit.
So.
Jetzt muss ich aber den Hocker benutzen,
weil die Schüssel zu hoch ist.
Also
das geht am besten, wenn ihr ein Handrührgerät nehmt
oder eben eine KitchenAid.
Jetzt verrühre ich die Butter mit dem Zucker
und der Prise Salz cremig.
Zimmerwarm.
Also die Butter ist zimmerwarm.
[Musik]
Wir brauchen die Seite 387.
Dreihundert...
So.
Weißer Maulwurfkuchen.
Ich habe das Vanilleextrakt vergessen.
Müsste ich mir vielleicht mal vorher
durchlesen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Jetzt wird es schon viel cremiger.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich das drei bis vier Minuten umgerührt.
Jetzt mache ich ein Ei nach dem anderen rein.
Es wird jetzt schon ein bisschen zum Teig.
[Musik]
Und jetzt mische ich das Backpulver mit dem Mehl.
Jetzt muss ich das Mehl langsam mit der Milch hineingeben
und dem Backpulver.
[Musik]
Jetzt gebe ich noch den Kakao dazu.
Oh!
Hey, guck mal hier rein!
Nun so.
Ich glaube, ich brauche ein bisschen mehr Mehl
– Milch, gell?
Oder?
[Musik]
Lecker.
Guck mal.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SAMIRA: Upsi!
So.
>> JOSH: Dir ist der Teig auf den Boden geflogen.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Und gerade eben habe ich auch den Ring,
also den Backring, mit
Backpapier eingeschlagen.
Also ich habe gerade eben den Backring eingeschlagen.
Und jetzt kommt da der Teig rein.
[Musik]
Och, ich will es jedes mal da dran streichen,
an den Rand.
Jetzt verteile ich den Teig ein bisschen im Backrahmen.
[Musik]
So.
Jetzt
mache ich meinen
unfert-
also rohen Teig in den Backofen.
>> JOSH: Auf was?
>> SAMIRA: Auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
[Musik]
Ich habe das noch nie gemacht.
Gleich. Bald.
Gleich drinnen.
So.
Drinnen.
Oder?
>> JOSH: Ja, glaube ich schon.
>> SAMIRA: So.
[Musik]
Für die Füllung innen drinnen brauchen wir
500 Gramm Sahne,
200 Gramm saure Sahne,
30 Gramm Puderzucker,
etwas San-apart zum Steifschlagen,
etwas
Vanilleextrakt
und 100 Gramm Schokodrops.
Ich habe hier
den Schneebesen, also den Aufsatz für die Sahne
Da in die Sahne gebe ich jetzt die saure Sahne rein.
Dann gebe ich noch den Puderzucker mit zu
– dazu.
[Klirren von Geschirr]
Ups! Das war laut.
Ein kleines bisschen Vanilleextrakt.
[Musik]
Ihr könnt auch dafür Tonka Wonka benutzen.
>> JOSH: Welches davon findest du besser?
>> SAMIRA: Beides.
Also Vanille kenne ich ja
besser.
Aber Tonka Wonka schmeckt auch richtig gut.
Jetzt rühre ich es rum
– um.
So, gell?
Und pro 100...
Pro 100 Gramm gebe ich jetzt einen Löffel
San-apart rein.
Das waren jetzt eineinhalb.
Zweieinhalb.
Vier.
Und sieben.
[Musik]
Wenn ich es so auf die Seite kippe,
spritzt es alles raus.
Cool.
[Musik]
Jetzt muss ich hier erst mal
von der Sahne eine Kostprobe machen.
Hm. Gut.
>> JOSH: Gut so?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SAMIRA: Drei Minuten und 59 Sekunden!
Der sieht richtig gut aus.
So.
Jetzt gehe ich nach draußen und
hole ein paar Erdbeeren und Minzblätter.
Himbeeren.
Und hier sind Erdbeeren.
Das sind Walderdbeeren.
Deswegen sind die so klein.
Oh!
[Musik]
Lieber mal mehrere holen.
Dann können wir mehr naschen.
Wo war Minze?
Eigentlich...
Ich glaube, dahinten.
>> JOSH: Ich glaube, in euren Hochbeeten, oder?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, stimmt!
Komm.
[Musik]
So.
Warte.
Ich muss kurz überlegen, was ich sagen will.
Ich überlege gerade!
Ich habe hier jetzt
die Sahne kurz in den Kühlschrank gemacht
für fünf Minuten ungefähr.
Und jetzt tue ich die Hälfe von den Schokodrops
hier unterheben.
So.
Also ihr müsst auch nicht alles reinmachen,
sondern halt nur ein bisschen.
Jetzt...
Warte. Stopp.
Sag, wann es passiert.
Ich habe hier jetzt die Sahne
und die Schokodrops reingemacht.
Und jetzt stelle ich sie in den Kühlschrank,
bis der Kuchen abgekühlt ist.
Gut.
Mein Kuchen ist gerade aus dem Backofen gekommen
und ist abgekühlt.
Und jetzt schneide ich die Erdbeeren.
Dass die später auch im Kuchen stehen können,
schneide ich einfach hier ein bisschen vom Kuchen ab
und lege das dann auf die Seite.
[Musik]
Die dürfen nicht zu klein sein.
So zum Beispiel wie die da hier.
Ja.
Weil sonst müsst ihr ganz viele davon pflücken.
Und
die könntet ihr dann als Deko benutzen.
[Musik]
Ich habe gerade eben den Kuchen...
Was habe ich?
Hä?
Noch mal.
Der Kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt
und jetzt lese ich...
Lese ich ihn von der Form?!
>> JOSH: Probiere es noch mal.
>> SAMIRA: Der Kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt
und
jetzt löse ich ihn von der Form.
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Jetzt tue ich meinen Kuchen auf einen Tortenretter.
Und
dort drauf mache ich dann
die Sahne und die Erdbeeren rein.
Oh, ich habe es geschafft.
Ich habe es schon geschafft!
Also ich habe jetzt hier einen kleineren
[Funkgeräusche]
Backring genommen.
Und
mit dem steche ich jetzt hier so eine,
so einen kleinen Kreis rein.
Oder nee. Warte.
Ich brauche dafür ein Messer.
Ups!
Ho!
So.
Und jetzt hole ich das mit der Hand raus.
Ihr könnt es natürlich auch mit einem Löffel rausnehmen.
Warte. Ich
brauche eine Schale.
Ich muss hier erst mal alles...
Ich habe alles im Video rausgeholt.
[Musik]
Oh, der ist richtig fluffig innen drinnen.
Ich glaube,
innen drinnen ist er doch noch ein bisschen warm.
Ein ganz, ganz mini bisschen.
[Musik]
Jetzt lege ich nacheinander die Erdbeeren drauf.
Das ist jetzt die Hälfte von den Schokodrops,
die ich noch hatte.
Und,
wenn man dann reinbeißt,
dass das so crunchy wird,
also halt knackt,
mache ich halt noch Schokodrops drüber,
über die Erdbeeren.
[Musik]
Jetzt mache ich die Creme drauf.
Jetzt muss ich es schon wieder holen,
den Teigschaber.
Mein Lieblingsteigschaber ist weg!
Den ich vorhin benutzt hatte!
>> JOSH: Guck mal. Ist der da noch in diesem Teil drin?
>> SAMIRA: Hm?
>> JOSH: Ist der da in dem Teil drin?
Ich glaube, der steckt noch drin.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Du weißt halt alles!
So.
Und jetzt tue ich hier die Creme drauf.
Am Anfang sieht das ein bisschen viel aus.
Aber
dann gibt es keinen schönen Maulwurfhügel,
wenn man nicht so viel Sahne benutzt.
Und jetzt streiche ich das so
runter.
Bei meiner Mama sah es irgendwie anders aus.
Oh!
Ups.
Ich streiche das jetzt so ein bisschen runter,
dass es halt den schönen Maulwurfhügel gibt.
Ist nicht schlimm, wenn man
hier zum Beispiel ein bisschen die Erdbeeren sieht.
Weil da kommen ja noch die Kekskrümmel drauf.
[Musik]
Ich muss jetzt den restlichen Teig hier,
denn wir rausgemacht haben,
ein bisschen zerbröseln,
dass ich ihn dann gleich anklatschen kann.
Jetzt nehme ich mir ein bisschen mit der Hand
und drücke es vorsichtig.
Der ist so wabberig!
Guck. Wui, wui!
Der Kuchen
hier in der Schale muss bröselig sein.
Weil sonst gibt es halt dicke Brocken
und dann kann man es nicht gut anschneiden
und es sieht halt auch nicht gut aus.
Wieder was auf den Boden gefallen!
Guck!
Siehst du?
Warte.
Hier die Lücke
wird gleich gestopft.
>> JOSH: Hm.
[Musik]
Guck!
Gestopft.
Ich frage mich, warum der Güni
keine Bananen isst.
Im Maulwurfkuchen schmeckt es richtig lecker!
Mit Erdbeeren habe ich es noch nie probiert
im Maulwurfkuchen.
>> JOSH: Den habe ich auch noch nie gegessen.
>> SAMIRA: Hast du auch nur mit Bananen gegessen?
Aber der Kuchen ist auch bestimmt richtig lecker.
>> JOSH: Ja, ich glaube, der wird richtig klasse.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist sogar mein Lieblingskuchen.
Ich muss immer auf der unteren Stufe sein,
weil, wenn ich auf der oberen bin, bin ich zu groß.
>> JOSH: Ja, vor allem hast du da
>> SAMIRA & JOSH: Kekskrümmel.
>> SAMIRA: Ich glaube, dass es klappt.
Bitte klapp!
So.
Ich brauche
– ich mache gerade die Deko –
einen Löffel.
Ich mache gerade die Deko.
Die Erde leuchtet ja auch.
Guck mal, wie viel da rauskommt.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Darf unser Gast auch kommen?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Uuh!
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe es ein bisschen schräg geschnitten.
>> SALLY: Ich muss echt sagen,
Samira, der Kuchen sieht fabelhaft aus!
Sehr, sehr, sehr schön!
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe es nicht durch die Mitte geschnitten.
>> SALLY: Macht nichts.
Soll ich dir kurz...
>> JULIA: Schmeckt bestimmt trotzdem, oder?
So gut, wie der aussieht.
>> SALLY: Hm!
Guck mal. Du kannst das Messer...
Ich weiß auch warum.
Weil du das Messer so hältst.
>> SAMIRA: Upsi!
>> SALLY: Wenn du es vielleicht so...
Genau.
>> SAMIRA: Aber
so.
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
Voll der schöne Maulwurfkuchen!
Julia, hast du schon mal Maulwurfkuchen gemacht?
>> JULIA: Nee.
>> SALLY: Siehst du?
>> JULIA: Also Samira ist mir ganz weit voraus.
>> SAMIRA: Ups.
>> SALLY: Ho!
>> JULIA: Wow!
>> SAMIRA: So.
>> SALLY: Lecker!
Wow!
>> SAMIRA: Warte. Die paar Erdbeeren hier.
>> SALLY: Ja, der Anschnitt beim ersten Stück
ist immer ein bisschen schwierig.
>> SAMIRA: So, die Erdbeeren.
>> SALLY: Voll schön gemacht!
Schatz, das ist echt toll!
>> JULIA: Ach, mit Erdbeeren. Lecker.
>> SAMIRA: Siehst du hier die Dinger?
>> SALLY: Ja, die Schokodrops!
>> JULIA: Ah!
>> SALLY: Hast du die noch so draufgelegt?
>> SAMIRA: Hm, wie du.
>> SALLY: Cool!
Okay.
Wir probieren.
>> SAMIRA: Wo soll ich das Messer hinmachen?
>> SALLY: Komm. Ich nehme es dir ab.
>> JULIA: Wollen wir gleichzeitig?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> JULIA: Warten wir gerade noch auf die Mama.
>> SALLY: Und los!
>> JULIA: Oh, ich habe eine Erdbeere.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich will auch eine Erdbeere.
>> JULIA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Okay, ich bin die Langsamste.
Oh, nein! Ich will auch Sahne!
>> JULIA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JULIA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Voll lecker!
>> JULIA: Ja.
Du hast ein eigenes Mini-Me.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Mein Mini-Me!
Und ab wann übernimmst du den Kanal?
>> JULIA: Ich würde sagen, ab morgen
und wir machen drei Tage frei, Sally.
>> SALLY: Ja, so machen wir das.
Also viel Spaß weiterhin
– ach so, ich moderiere gar nicht.
Samira, das ist deine Moderation.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Warte.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Ich muss gerade voll lachen.
>> SALLY: Du darfst aber ruhig meine App benutzen.
Also wir können deine Rezepte auch in meine App laden.
Okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Wenn du noch keine eigene programmieren willst.
Okay?
Also, wenn du möchtest,
kannst du dein Rezept in meine App laden.
Okay?
Cool! Da würde ich mich freuen.
Wie so ein Gastbeitrag.
>> JULIA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Weißt du? Da gibt es doch so Blogs
und dann machen die so Gastbeiträge.
Samira, ich bin echt stolz auf dich!
Du hast richtig einen ganz, ganz tollen
Maulwurfkuchen gemacht.
Mit Erdbeeren aus unserem Garten,
hier die kleinen da oben.
>> SAMIRA: Das sind Walderdbeeren.
>> SALLY: So süß!
>> JULIA: Also megalecker,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JULIA: Schatzi!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Vielen Dank, dass wir probieren durften!
Gleich schneiden wir uns noch ein Stückchen ab.
Und?
>> SAMIRA: Viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> SAMIRA: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Hat es Spaß gemacht?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Cool!
>> JULIA: Boah, lecker, Schatzi!
>> SALLY: Süße Maus.
>> JULIA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Richtig gut!
Ich nehme auch das Stück, was hier drauf ist.
>> JULIA: Glücklich?
Stolz?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und ich auch!
>> JULIA: Ich finde es ja cool, dass ich direkt
dabei sein durfte!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JULIA: Da kommst du einmal zu Besuch
und da ist sie beim ersten Video dabei.
O mein Gott!
Du bist eigentlich viel zu groß.
Können wir die nicht noch mal in den Kindergarten geben?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JULIA: Nicht dass die...
Ja, nicht dass...
>> SALLY: Komm, wir machen sie kleiner.
Wir machen sie kleiner.
>> JULIA: Ja, genau, ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Ganz schnell kleiner machen.
Oh, ja!
Oh!
Oh, so mag ich dich wieder!
O mein armes, kleines Baby!
So ist es doch viel schöner!
Dann kommt sie gar nicht alleine an die Sachen ran.
>> SALLY: So klein bleibst du jetzt für immer.
>> SAMIRA: Nein.
>> SALLY: Nein!
Tschüss!
Ich hoffe, ihr habt auch so tolle Kinder,
die so toll backen können.
Süße Maus.
Iss auf.
Soll ich den Kuchen halten?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
Also.
Und dann kann Papa auch mitessen.
Voll gut!
>> SAMIRA: Ja, richtig lecker!
[Musik]